i love awkward and i love that and we
have always you talk about those sitcoms
now you know they have to have moral
comeuppance yeah if somebody does
something bad then they gotta
win that or lose at the end that's not
that takes away from comedy right you
know and i also think this is maybe
going down the wrong road but uh i i was
realized how like in the 80s we grew up
with a lot of
uh
kind of
like right and i'm saying like
necessarily political but i guess maybe
political kind of a right-wing
perspective on the world like police
academy right uh i think bill murray and
those kind of movies have this
not it's hard to put a thing on but it's
it's [ __ ] who are rewarded
for being [ __ ] does that make sense
what does that do it it kind of
emboldens a ideology i think maybe i
haven't fully thought
yeah just sort of like you you're you
should be
uh like you can you can succeed if
you're a jerk
kind of but it's like a bully
like peter pan i told you this what's
the peter pan peter pan was rewarded and
he was looked at as the hero but really
he's the one that was kidnapping kids
and hook was trying to stop him all
right that's a good point right right so
hook was actually what it would have to
do with this i'm just saying we're
we're rewarding
the [ __ ] and peter pan is the [ __ ]
who is stealing kids it's interesting
that's all i'll say
that's a good point we'll edit that into
another podcast
because we're talking about comedy but
the truth no i get what you're saying no
but it is the same thing it's how people
view whatever it is they're watching and
listening to and how that kind of
affects our life but the truth is at the
same time it is
comedy is very um
myopic in the sense that who's ever
watching it and whoever that audience is
you know it's not the same kind of
audience that will like
the bill murray movie that might like
um
i'm trying to think of at the time
there's different kinds of comedy
there's a lot of different you know
within our own community in the comedy
community we are the harshest critics of
each other i was always
um disrespected and made fun of i'm sure
always and that's because at the
beginning when i started like that and i
was doing prop comics i talked to scott
carritop all the time carrot top has to
create whatever it is and whether you
like it i think he's a brilliant guy he
is building props yeah
writing live creative and not only that
it's successful yeah phil's he's been in
at the luxor he's got his own room for
10 years there's a lot of lesser comics
that
that uh put him down right he has the
ability easy punchline does he how does
he feel about it this is horrible he
feels terrible yeah okay and i did too
for years i was the punchline and on
letterman's top ten
and uh you know the tenth thing and
we'll make him sit through a howie
mandela concert right you know but
within as opposed to somebody who was
just a uh a brilliant monologist who
talked about uh political things and
things that were happening in the paper
you know those people were kind of
lauded the truth
and then if you're doing things that are
silly
and off then you're oh we get low class
i mean but that's the dichotomy where we
often get talked about in very high brow
terms because of our art the kind of the
art artistic side of our work
but also are just derided for being
nothing but poop jokes and brown and you
know like just low class
weird for the sake of weird by all kinds
of people and then in the middle ground
is sort of the serious comedians who
don't think what we do is
is funny i think what you do is beyond
funny i think what you do is beyond
maybe coming from me it doesn't mean
anything in the world but
i really truly believe that you have a
higher level of comedy and you build a a
a world not only there's a world there's
a there's a um
a patina to whatever that tim eric world
was yeah and even and and that is even
more than sounding like the guy who has
always made it onto the tonight show
talking about you know commercials and
right things like that or waiting for or
how to reset the microwave uh timer
right
god bless that stuff too i don't i mean
i like it i'm not knocking that stuff
yeah yeah i'm just saying that that was
held in a steam where i think that doing
that is kind of easier than what you do
and and what you do as a group and what
you need to do in concert together you
know you have to be in front of the
camera you guys have to cut what you see
you have to take things that already
exist on another level and then re-cut
it and make it mean something totally
different just by editing so i am such a
huge fan of everything you do i uh i
wanted to have you here today because
i'm begging to work with you in any
capacity yeah all three of you this is a
dream come true no yeah i mean like a
dream come true
complimenting little monsters because
that's like huge for me i don't know oh
thank you it's huge and my kids thank
you but he wants to look forward he
doesn't want to look back i know i know
but now he doesn't want to look but feel
i have a little facility here if you
ever want to come and do stuff that i'm
not in why don't we pitch normal-sized
monsters that'll be the sequel
normal-sized monsters i love that
whatever that is we'll figure it out
[Music]